there is new data from Spotify showing
just how badly our attention span is
crumbling
you might have stopped watching this
already I'm only six seconds then I
think by
they have shown that people are skipping
songs to the point
love addiction to it let's look at the
research
binding nearly a quarter of all songs on
Spotify gets get within five
second starting that's basically 25
percent a corner on that a mathematician
basically that
up more than a third are skipped within
30 seconds
nearly half a ball Saunders kept at some
point so even if you love
your popular with the kids the fiance
use does get better
and 18 show the most inclination to skip
but there's an increase for those in
their mid-forties
as well I guess that this should be
surprising I we're all doing this all
day long with their phones were all
tweeting and I again I admit that I'm on
this stuff all the time
I but there's something I thought
interesting that related to music now
to like even music we're losing our
attention
ability fragmented attention I find that
to be the case and I and actually as
you sent as I was reading a story I
realize I had a video playing in the
background
that I was also be listening to but I
got bored and so it went over and
checked something else on it
oh my gosh I'm doing it right now yeah
yeah cell
were you tweeting while I was reading
that have no I was looking away were you
29 are facebooking
there's a different app involved there
but yes you know I yeah
but i think is given the opportunity
didn't change
what's happening we're gonna take it
right mean how many times as you listen
to the radio and Nickelback song came on
your like cheese
exactly what happened through the thing
I wanna skip it before five seconds
without
and I think if you have your playlist
set up you know you've got songs that
you
you know select a listen to maybe you
just don't feel like listening to write
them
come back to Dayton Arnova necessarily
an example or I'd
at reason to say like were just a little
crazy and outta control
like works we're doing what we with the
whole point the thing is it's like
digging your choice and you're using
your exercising your choice yes I'm good
you
went there immediately cuz I do agree
with that as a basic principle that
maybe this
is just the next step is we seem to
think everything's bad you know
everything's getting faster at shorter
whatever
but I do think there's a chance that
maybe where
sorted were allowing our brains to work
on other things because you don't
because this short term thing you can do
by think that what you can now watch a
video
and that you would probably you that be
okay have music on n be tweeting
and we're doing maybe we are really why
we talk about the rewiring a vibrant
and maybe we are requiring a good way is
that possible I think absolutely
you know where our brains our brains are
as humans we are so adaptable our brains
are adapting to this new reality that
we've created for sales and
you know maybe the reason why we're
switching is because we really couldn't
before
before your limit gambling on the radio
right then and whatever you could switch
to that might be interesting or your
cassette tapes you know
so we had the fact they were actually in
a place now where
we can choose for ourselves and have
this wide menu to choose from on our own
maybe that's what our brains naturally
always wanted to do yeah well I didn't
because then you know the meeting in all
honesty yeah I mean to me I'm an idiot
way it comes out lol delivering yeah
triangulate
yeah well I think you're right about the
radio thing because this past weekend I
was driving up to
datasets from l8r six-hour drive and I
was doing the
the radio thing just FM radio and I
realized how quickly
you I don't even know if it was five
seconds that I could hear a song
and immediately switch so maybe this
isn't that well there's a lot more
garbage music out there for some it now
for real
yeah because it me I used to work
musicals in a band you know it a lot
easier to make music not a lot easier to
get your music on Spotify
you just have to basically pay $49
boxing it shows up there so it's like
all that interesting so just you think
there's more garbage into at all so yeah
the level love but you know the barriers
to entry have come down so much with the
advent of technology recording
technology specifically
that more people are able to make more
things if you search for a song that you
like on Spotify
you know let's use your favorite be on
sale I can just talk yet you'll find to
be right there
gonna turn or more but I was yeah Wow
well I'm
anyway I if you buy be a I'm off by
track
thanks Tina Turner you know yeah ride on
the freeway not not me
a if you look at at that Beyonce song is
only four different cover versions of
that by like a local bands from Idaho
you know and and they're not very good
sorry so of course you're gonna right so
we just made the pool bigger and bigger
well I wonder how much we can
extrapolate from this particular study
you know great that they have all these
metrics Spotify that they can actually
look into
oh my God look when they they they pay
peek at this time in the day great how
to do it a Spotify
NBA pick you know I am but as far as how
much we can extrapolate from at the
actual
fragmentation attention spans from
people I think Spotify is very specific
because
you know it is more hands on than just
turning on something like Pandora in the
background just letting its use for you
that randomization
so if it's more hands-on then it's gonna
show more people are going to have more
fragmented attention
because it requires you to do that
address bar but
you know I don't know that means that
that is necessarily want a bad thing and
to that it's happening really as much as
this but if its specific study with
India indicate ray not be that it's
like that as much for everybody may just
be that that's because that's how spot
by workmen
yet so I like they were being pro
attention and a tension here were given
were given to both side
but then I was thinking you know could
we ever have a classical music
come back were you know anywhere you
really listen to one piece
for 20 minutes or could it could have
both me and perhaps it even ever be
written now
you know because we're so in this Katy
Perry
turned out as you said you know a you
now have these you
been all these pop songs come out
there's literally teams have like 40
people just coming up with some stupid
repetitive
be could we ever have sorta Wong
form music actually come back or is that
really
that I think the nature of how the music
business work today you know
figuring out the formula is to have a
popular song you're talking the
difference between
commercially popular for its artistic
yes so as long as artists have an
opportunity to get their music and their
work
out to a wider audience you know we
don't have the same system that we used
to have a classical music
you know if they're able to get it out
there then I think
yeah now then we will still have the
resurgence or ordered the survival of
classical music and longer
one piece I think so badly residents are
yeah well the good thing about having
more opportunities to get more music out
is that then as a fan bases go
they're able to be segmented more so if
you just into that one thing
you can go and find that the formulaic
process up the music industry has been
going on since around nineteen
50 I'm sure I mean it like you know that
you look at a pop song many like a pop
song now
got corporations got be there very much
the same as recycling over
but if your consumer you are no longer
just getting your music from the MTV
or around the radio you know you can go
out any you would like to listen to
about a coltrane record go for you know
do it
or the new partner call tracker run over
that is Tina Turner K
yeah well I wonder how many have you
actually watch this entire video
that would be I guess the ultimate
lesson in this
would be that so let us know in the
comments down below